well you probably heard about house
arrest and bail or bond those are
alternatives to being in jail while
you're
awaiting trial but did you know accused
murderers are not always in custody
the i-team's vanessa murphy takes a
closer look at both sides of this issue
at least 35 defendants charged with
murder in clark county
are not in jail the circumstances vary
a woman who police say shoved an elderly
man off a bus
a security guard accused of killing a
man on the job
and several alleged acts of domestic
violence
at least nine are accused of killing
children
most of them their own he paid less
for his bond than the cost of my child's
funeral veronica melton's son giovanni
was 14 years old
her ex-husband wendell melton is accused
of shooting him back in 2017
because he was gay today he's on house
arrest awaiting trial
utterly perplexing i don't understand
the system
metro deputy chief laz chavez says on
average
30 to 40 people charged with murder are
not behind bars
that's about 10 percent of open murder
cases right now
it's frustrating it's frustrating for
the police department metro police keep
track of electronic monitoring and house
arrest
some of the worst crimes which is the
taking the life of another human being
is that the one where you get to go home
or not
i would argue that it's not you're
innocent until proven guilty
ozzy fumo is a criminal defense attorney
just because the accusation is made
that someone has committed a crime
doesn't mean they're guilty of that
crime you know
there's a process for it the burden
falls on prosecutors to convince a judge
to keep the person in jail
in 99 of these cases the district
attorney's office
seeks a significant bail district
attorney steve wolfson says that maybe
as much as a million dollars in some
cases
it's always up to the judge the judges
make the ultimate decision
the judge considers whether the
defendant will be a danger to the
community
according to metro from 2018 to 2020
eight defendants charged with murder who
were on house arrest were accused of
committing new crimes
including assault sex offense and more
the judge also considers whether a
defendant will willingly return to court
the department reports no defendants
charged with murder fled over the past
two years but in 2019 christopher
prestopino was a no-show
he's accused of killing a woman and
dumping her body in the desert
he posted a 500 thousand dollar bond
police found him at his house while he
was supposed to be in court
and took him back to jail it took the
wind out of the sales of
all of us thinking that this is the one
who meets the criteria for house arrest
the i-team examined court records to
find out whether
certain judges were more likely to grant
bail house arrest or electronic
monitoring
for defendants charged with murder and
we found
no major trends i think now we're
finally
equaling the scales of justice because
we have judges who understand the law we
will continue to
investigate these crimes what happens
afterwards
needs to be in my opinion needs to be
looked at and
may be reconsidered wolfson says a
defendant out of custody can
sometimes delay a case if a defendant
isn't in jail he says their legal team
may not hesitate in asking for
continuances
veronica melton says she's been waiting
more than three years
for justice but the action and the
result is still the same i still have a
child
vanessa murphy eight news now in one
case the i-team found that bail was
reduced for the defendant due to covid19
according to court records he had asthma
metro police say as of thursday 15
inmates had coveted 19 and were in
isolation
deputy chief chavez insists there is
room for defendants charged with murder
to be safely housed metro reports 36
percent vacancy